>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> SPEAKER 1: And is everybody ready
for the third annual
Youth Poetry Slam?
[ Cheers ]
The inaugural slam in 2014
featured teen performers
from around the district.
And last year we expanded the event
to include teens from
across the country.
So, this year we are delighted
to welcome three national teams
to join DC's Youth Slam Team on
the stage and, brace yourself;
they are from Des Moines,
Iowa RunDSM.
[ Cheers ]
From Indianapolis,
Indiana Indy Pulse.
[ Cheers ]
And from New York City, Urban Word.
Our host tonight will say more
about the format of the poetry slam,
but before I invite him up, I want
to thank a number of organizations
for collaborating with the Library
of Congress on this wonderful event.
First, the National
Endowment for the Arts,
our fellow federal arts agency
that helps us bring poets
and writers to this festival.
Three cheers for the
National Endowment.
[ Cheers ]
And, Split This Rock.
The literary organization
that helps us reach
out to our competing slam teams.
[ Cheers ]
I would especially like to thank
NEA Literature Division director,
Amy Stolls.
And Split This Rock executive
director, Sarah Browning
for their efforts to bring
America's best youth slammers
to this book festival.
[ Cheers ]
So, tonight we have a
terrific lineup of judges.
Two of them are acclaimed
writers who earlier
in the day participated
in the festival.
The first is poet, Joy Harjo.
And author Meg Medina.
Thank you both for extending
your time to be here today.
[ Applause ]
And now fasten your seatbelt,
I'm pleased to announce
that our third judge for
tonight is the 14th Librarian
of Congress, Dr. Carla Hayden.
[ Cheers ]
So, thank you judges.
So, I'd now like to turn the
mic over to tonight's host,
Joseph Green, Split This Rock's
acting youth program's coordinator.
Joseph is also the co-founder and
program director of Poetry Now,
and after school creative writing
program for DC area students.
And he has over 10 years' experience
as a professional spoken
word, artist and writer.
So, Joseph it's all yours.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Good evening.
How are you?
Are you ready for a
poetry slam [cheers]?
All right so, I'm going to
give that like a D plus.
No I mean like you
showed up to class.
You didn't know what
class you were in
and you didn't bring any utensils.
All right.
No pencil.
No paper, nothing.
All right so we're
going to try it again.
But I'm going to give you some
things to think about this time.
This is a poetry slam.
So, when I ask you to applaud, I
want you to applaud like the future
of our country is going to get on
this stage and open themselves up
and share with you the keys to how
to make this world a better place.
All right?
[ Cheers ]
That was just like one thing.
But you seem to understand
what I mean, right.
So, every time a poet
comes on stage tonight,
that the sort of acclaim
they should meet.
All right I say it like
this to my other audiences.
Imagine your first-born child
has just won a spelling bee,
in a language you did not
know they could speak.
That is amazing.
And that's how we should
treat every young person
that comes on this stage tonight.
So, one more time for
our wonderful performers.
[ Cheers ]
As you heard before, this event
is brought to you by the Library
of Congress, The National Endowment
of the Arts, and Split This Rock.
Please put your hands together
for those amazing groups.
[ Applause ]
And we have poets from
all over the country.
All right, so this time I'm
going to say the name of the team
and I want you all to applaud like
we just learned how we're going
to applaud for the rest, all right.
From Des Moines RunDSM [cheers].
From Indianapolis,
Indy Pulse [cheers].
From New York City,
Urban Word [cheers].
And from Washington DC, Split
This Rock's DC U Slam Team.
[ Cheers ]
So, to keep things fair, that
will be the last time this evening
until after the performance
that you will hear the names
of the participating
groups, because we don't have
to have any home team advantage.
But please understand that
these young people worked hard
on these poems.
They travelled from all
over the country to be here
to share these words with you
and that is a special thing.
Now, show of hands, how many
of you have ever been
to a poetry slam before?
Good. Good, good, good.
So, you know everything
I'm about to say.
This is for everybody
else in the room.
A poetry slam is a competition
that was started in the mid-1980s
by a construction worker in
Chicago named Mark Smith.
>> CROWD: So, what?
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Exactly.
In this competition people will
compete with original pieces
of poetry, not going
over three minutes.
There will be no musical
accompaniment, no props,
no costumes, anything of that sort.
All right.
These poems are original
constructions of these young people
so I just want to really drive that
home that these are their thoughts,
their words, their ideas about
the world and they are welcome,
welcoming to you after to
come up and talk to them
and ask them about these things.
We hope that you take these
ideas home and you discuss them.
If this poetry slam is no
more than clapping and scores,
then we have failed here today.
So please keep that in mind.
Other things you need to know
about the poetry slam
is there will be judges.
They will judge from 0 to 10;
10 being the best poem you have
ever heard, the roof falls out,
everybody ascends to heaven.
That's it.
It's over.
That's a 10.
Zero, being the opposite of
that, the bottom falls out,
everyone goes to hell,
it's over, no.
But they have been prepped.
They know that they are
judging on performance
and they are judging on content.
Now, it's a hard job to judge, okay.
So, judges, I'm going to
introduce you one more time
and you're going to get applause.
This might be the last
applause you hear tonight.
But, you deserve it.
You are experts in your craft and
that's why we choose you okay?
All right.
So, again, poet, musician
and playwright Joy Harjo.
[ Cheers ]
The Librarian of Congress,
Carla Hayden[cheers].
And YA author of "Burn Baby
Burn" and Yaqui Delgado Wants
to Kick Your Ass," Meg Medina.
[ Cheers ]
Judges, do not be swayed
by the audience.
All right.
We picked you on purpose.
There's a reason why
you're here, all right.
Audience, sway the judges all right.
When they throw a score up and
you do not like that score,
we don't do booing any
more we don't do that,
we say, 'listen to the poem.'
Everyone say, 'listen to the poem.'
>> CROWD: Listen to the poem.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Exactly.
And that's how they
know how you feel.
If they throw up a score that
you love, you do what [cheers]?
You applaud riotously.
All right.
And [laugther].
It's a very rough crowd.
That's okay we have security
for the judges afterwards.
No, this is about the poetry.
We will clap for the scores.
You will scream listen to the
score if you don't like the score.
But at the end of the day,
the poetry is the point.
I say again, the poetry
is the point.
These young people and their
words are what matters the most,
we just do this competition thing
to get people out in the seats
because this is America and
we love a good competition.
All right.
But the fact of the matter is
we are here to hear some poetry.
If you're ready to hear
some poetry make some noise.
[ Cheers ]
You're not ready yet.
So, it is a tradition
at the poetry slam,
that we have a calibrating poet.
We call them the sacrificial.
They come, they spill their
blood on the stage for you.
Judges, they will be the litmus for
all of your scores for here on out.
If you like a poem more,
give it a higher score.
If you like a poem less
give it a lower score.
All right.
This poet is not in the competition.
But, they will be scored
as if they are.
Please, this is your first test.
Coming to the stage, please
put your hands together
for Ushindi Performance
Group member,
Yonus O'Ria [assumed spelling].
[ Cheers ]
[ Applause ]
>> YONUS O'RIA: How you all doing?
This is loud.
All right, cool.
I'm going to do a love poem, because
like who doesn't like love poems.
You know? Cool.
If I was brave enough to be your
Romeo would you be my Juliette?
Would you find me important
enough to be in your poems?
Would you bring me up in random
conversation with people I've met?
Would you believe me when I tell
you, you are you own worst critic?
See, everything you do is sunsets on
countrysides, drops of rain dancing
across a baby's forehead
for the first time.
You are nothing less
than a treasure.
I know that people have loved
you for all the wrong reasons.
If I was brave enough to show you
the right ones, would you let me?
I've been thinking of how
to tell you how I feel.
Or, if you would even believe me.
See, you've met the worst parts
of me before the best parts.
Got a chance to shine.
If I was brave enough to take
the time would you let me get
to know you?
Not just the picture-perfect smile,
or face you put on for others,
would you let me know the
reason you wear the masks?
See, this isn't a crush
or teenage lust,
but I wouldn't feel
comfortable calling it love
because I don't just want
to kiss, and hug you,
or know all your secrets.
You make me want to be the man
I don't ever think I can be.
Your words fuel my inspiration.
My skin dances to the
sound of your voice.
When you speak, I don't
get butterflies.
I get riots of unspoken
words demanding refuge,
raging pulse of fire in
the midnight of my stomach,
I wish the flames could dance of my
tongue as easily as they do yours.
You are the night before
my revolution.
I ask you.
If I was brave enough to be your
Romeo, would you be my Juliette?
So, could we trash all the
metaphors, get rid of the
over used clichés and
not so well done similes
and simply help each other be
the best versions of ourselves?
[ Cheers ]
JOSEPH GREEN: A couple of important
things I want to point out there.
Some of poetry slam veterans
reminded me that I forgot
to say something at the beginning.
This is not a poetry reading.
This is not a golfing event.
This is a poetry slam.
All right.
So, if you hear something you
like while it's happening,
it is encouraged for
you to reciprocate
that energy back to
the poet, all right.
There are several ways
you can do that.
If you hear a poem, if
you hear a line in a poem
that you really like you can snap.
Let me hear everybody snap.
Yes. Sounds like the biggest
bowl or Rice Krispies.
Second thing you do if
you hear something you
like you can say, 'word.'
Everyone say, 'word.'
>> CROWD: Word.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: All right
now this is my favorite thing
in the world invented by Amine
Drulaw [assumed spelling],
you can take the word she,
you can take the word Jesus
and you smoosh it together
and if you hear something
that makes you feel holy on
the inside you say, 'shesus.'
Everybody on the count of three,
let me hear your best shesus.
One, two, three.
>> CROWD: Shesus.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: There
it is all right.
So, from now on the poets
are prepared for this.
You're not being rude.
All right they know this is coming.
The snapping is preferred
because they can keep going.
But if something really, just
give it to them, it's good,
it's beautiful all right.
So, judges this is the longest
amount of time you will ever have
to put your scores
together all right.
So, this is the scoring part.
Judges, may I see your
scores in 3, 2.
You all was supposed
to have it written
down already, 3, 2, 1 scores up.
From Low to high I
have a 9.0, a 9.1,
and a 9.5 let's hear
it for the poet please.
[ Applause ]
All right and because this
is the National Book Fair,
there is a twist to
this poetry slam.
There's a theme.
All right so for the
first round the poets have
to present a poem about
books, or reading.
All right.
That is a very broad theme it can
be interpreted in many, many ways.
I look forward to seeing how
many ways they interpret it.
Okay. But that's the first round.
The second round will be
a poem of their choice.
Now do you all want to hear the
names of the people who are going
to blow this stage up tonight,
make some noise [cheers].
All right this is also the
order they will be going
in in the first round, please
save your applause to the end
so they can hear this and remember.
We have Alyssa Gaines
[assumed spelling],
Shintelli Medina [assumed
spelling], Kaysa [assumed spelling],
Kenya [assumed spelling],
Julio [assumed spelling],
Henry [assumed spelling], Kalyn
Basquez [assumed spelling],
and Elondra Brassil
[assumed spelling].
Put your hand together
for the poets.
[ Cheering ]
Keep that energy going
for the first poet,
in the first round, Alyssa Gaines.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
>> Baby do your thing.
>> Okay poet now let's get
in formation [laughter].
>> ALYSSA GAINES: Where
is my chariot?
Where I've been waiting.
I've been stuck here for so long.
Nobody hears my cries.
My cage song.
He woke up this morning, got out of
bed, got ready to chase the big blue
and yellow exhaust pumping the city
dragon which took him to school.
Little did he know he'd be
fighting many battles that day.
He'd be battling many monsters
and even breaking a few rules.
Jabril, our hero rode the
dragon until it stopped
at his stop then he got off and
walked to the schoolhouse, 8:30.
The was 30 minutes early, never
neglecting to say, 'good morning.'
But sometimes forgetting to
finish the homework of last night.
At last the bell rung and he rushed
to his place, sat in his seat
and prepared for the
monster he was about to face.
This big, ugly monster
wanted to incarcerate him.
The monster who never
wanted to see him graduate.
The monster who tried
to hold him down,
keep his head to the ground
and tell him his fate.
Which the monster, statistic,
made to seem set in stone.
Our hero slayed the
beast of the classroom
and their preconceived notions.
He fought the rude things they said
and the negative things
they told him.
He fought the ideas that
the naturally grown hair
from his head was nappy
and that was bad.
He fought for the education
he deserved to have.
He fought the giant of not having
all the tools that he needed.
He fought the feign, the fighting
to catch the dragon to get home.
He fought the students who crossed
him not knowing his struggles,
and fought punishments
more than he deserved.
And he fought most of
these battles alone.
And sometimes it got hard
wielding swords of open smarts
and that's why he needed
the schoolhouse every day.
He needed to learn how to
craft things other kids got
for their birthdays.
Laptops, Wi-Fi, a school board
mom, and automatic good grades.
Nobody saw in him the
vision that he saw.
Nobody thought that
he would ever go far.
Nobody thought his dreams
would ever come true,
but Jabril, I believe in you.
You're paving your own yellow brick
road, wielding your own weapons
with your melanin and afro.
Fighting battles to help you succeed
and keeping hope when it's hard
to believe, or else you wouldn't
chase the evermoving dragon
every day.
Oh, Jabril.
He never does his work, he
doesn't care of school work at all,
is what the monsters all
say to try to throw him off.
But, hero keep your head up.
None of that is true.
And if everyone thinks
it is, I believe in you.
You are worth so much
time and so much patience.
Jabril, you are worth
a decent education.
They see the habits you've
developed to survive on the streets
and try to take them at school.
Beasts confiscate them at school
as they try to teach you to fit
in in a society that
doesn't even want you to.
But I believe in you.
Stay firm in your beliefs,
participate, write, and read.
And I know you recognize that
the teaching tools are twisted,
but do what you need to do
in this education system.
And once you finish school,
you can help to fix it.
And all the problems of our world.
Beautiful black boys and girls,
you are all like the hero
from our story today.
No matter what anyone
does, or what anyone says,
you hold so much potential
and so much value.
Black youth, I believe in you.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Best part
of being a host is walking
up during someone else's applaud
and pretending like it's for you.
As a host, I am not allowed to
talk about the poems as they go
through so you all have to make
sure that when a poem comes up here
that really moves you,
you let that poet know.
Judges you have 3, 2, 1.
Scores up from low to high I
have a 9.2, a 9.5, and a 9.5.
Let's hear it for the poet.
[ Cheers ]
Coming up next.
Please put your hands
together for Shintelli Medina.
[ Applause ]
All the way to the stage folks,
all the way to the stage.
Don't give up.
[ Applause ]
>> SHINTELLI MEDINA: They say,
if you want to hide something
from my people, put it in the book.
The best way they have
hidden everything from us was
by burning the ones we wrote.
How dare you rewrite me into
history as if I be fiction.
Hand me a book that
sanctions my slavery.
Command of me to praise to a
man that mirrors my conqueror.
I cannot fall bended knee to a
father after mine was stripped
from me like the dignity
of my people.
Do you know how it feels
to take up 10 pages
of an American history textbook
that make up more than 1/3
of the population and feel
like misrepresentation.
And feel like misogyny.
And feel like misery.
And feel like I am pretend fighting
for a right to be real in a world
that want to see me erased.
I can't. They won't erase me.
Do you know what it feels like
to have to go and pray to a God
that doesn't look like you?
Do you know what it feels
like to not be able to rewind
and track a tribe that
belongs to you?
Think back to a time where you
felt incomplete, inadequate.
felt like you were only half
of something you thought
you were holistically.
Imagine being Hispanic, stuck
in between black void
and white privilege.
Stuck in between two blood lines.
One that calls island
home, and that yeans
to rape island of all that it is.
Hoping that you knew your skin.
That you could pick a kin.
Thank you.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges,
because we have to, in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high I have
an 8.9, a 9.0 and a 9.0.
Can we hear one more
time for the poet please.
[ Applause ]
It's not easy.
Coming up here, opening yourself up.
Laying yourself down like that.
I have been in this work for
about a decade and the courage
of the young people that I see on
a day-to-day basis having the nerve
to do this inspire me endlessly.
So, for all the young people
that have picked up a pen,
that have stepped on this stage,
or will step on this stage,
I need a lot more applaud than that.
[ Cheering ]
Coming up next.
Please keep that going for Kaysa.
[ Cheering ]
>> KAYSA: It is twilight.
Onto day break long after
the moon has been tucked away
and the stars have left the sky.
It is here in this eerie place
Edward Cullen finds himself
enthralled in the very
thoughts of his love, Bella.
He is compelled and moved by her.
It is she that protects his hallowed
soul with the shield of ignorance.
And ignorant are the
boards of Indiana,
the state that just won't say yes.
The state who continues to
press the LGBT community.
I remember the feeling of
being utterly dumbfounded
by a fair maiden's appearance.
Yes, I was physically attracted to
her, but it was the blood coursing
through her body and heat
that radiated from her chest
that I knew there was
something deeper.
And so deep into the
night I thought about her.
I also found myself dreaming in the
day as thoughts of her lean metallic
like features danced
across my brain.
My brain, having been
stepped on by my governor.
His proud hooves engraving state
laws of restoration in my mind.
Telling me to think straight and
I knew it could never happen.
And it can never be possible like
Edward who's 107, and Bella 17,
and myself a junior
and she a freshman.
It was wrong.
But it didn't change the fact
that I wanted it to happen.
But maybe I am more like Jacob.
Hot-headed, ill-tempered, and a bit
jealous in my love, the new moon.
Unsure personality sexuality,
a quarter of a moon shore,
half of a moon shore,
waxing full, waning gone.
It is new moon when
Jacob goes to the faces.
From the slightest
thing could turn him.
Action, reaction.
From a wholesome human
being in two feet,
to a ferocious beast on the prowl.
Fire in his eyes.
Rage in his growl.
And I'm no beast, but my eyes begin
to glisten in nervous laughter.
I keep highs in my vocal
cords when I see her.
The slightest thing could turn me.
The gleam in her smile, the dolls
on her eyes that could the stars
or the sweet aroma of her presence
that gets carried away
with the wind.
My love knows there's an
opposing force out there.
A force that is not for all rights.
A force that will pray,
hunt and kill.
Anyone not in alliance
with the church and state.
The world of twilight
causes a new born army.
My world causes homophobic
politics and corrupted saints.
Both are newly changed,
untrained vampires, blood thirsty,
power hungry, and will do
anything for a coat of normality.
What is normal?
What is freedom?
What is love?
It keeps hurting me, a wooden dagger
through my chest which is refract.
My Christianity cannot
be healed by this wound.
Where's my freedom to love, to pray,
to get down on my knees and confess
to another woman that I am
dangerously in love with her.
I am breaking so many rules here.
She is the moon.
I am the sun.
And for a moment in time
we are perfectly aligned.
The gravitational pull of
human emotion between us.
And as we separate, our eclipse
fades, and day begins to break.
Breaking news, Indiana has just
passed the religious freedom
restoration act, pressing
same sex and gender laws
like tending to our corn fields.
And this is what we're known for.
Like men who shave sheep into wools,
and then stalking the sweet
aroma of their next victim.
But it's not always that easy.
We don't always get to choose
what it's like to love someone.
The Bible and the Constitution
rejects.
A sinner and a criminal.
Like the moment a wolf
imprints on another human being.
Fate has decided the
love of your life.
And fate is what brings
worlds together.
Colliding them in space
in time, drawing parallels
between fantasy and reality.
And this is reality.
Are you the protagonist,
or the antagonist?
Choose wisely, the future
of our saga depends on it.
The future of my sage depends on it.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high, I have an 8.9.
>> CROWD: Listen to the poem.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: A 9.1, and a 9.2.
Clap for the poet please.
[ Applause ]
So, another important
announcement that I neglected
to make at the beginning.
Hey everybody, turn
your cellphones off.
Turn them to sting, stun
anything that does not make noise.
We do not want to hear
your Lil Wayne ringtone
in the middle of one of these poems.
You know who I'm talking
about Sarah Browning.
No, but seriously, turn them off,
but use them with this hash tag.
National Book Fest.
Yes, let people know
that this room right now
on a Saturday night is full of young
people who like words [applause].
Who love words.
Who are passionate about
books, and reading,
and can articulate that passion.
All right.
they don't know we're out
here, we need to tell them.
Use that hash tag National
Book Fest.
All right now, clear the room
it's time for our next poet.
Please put your hands together,
start clapping right now
for Kenya [applause].
It's time to go all the
way to the stage please.
There it is.
[ Applause ]
>> KENYA: It was on a
Wednesday, during my 11 a class.
Oh, sorry.
It was on a Wednesday, during
my 11 a.m. chemistry class
when a butterfly placed
itself up on a student's desk.
And I've never seen something
so graceful, full of freedom.
All nature and God wrapped
into a seamless body.
In chemistry, we are taught that
the world is made of matter.
Full of lively atoms
that shoot their ray
across dimensions, break barriers.
Like the butterfly.
But today, he was not
celebrated as such there.
There'd be no projects made in his
honor, never rejoice in his colors,
execute him to black and white.
My professor called
it the circle of life.
Necessary for science.
Like splitting mocking birds open
and claiming their
voice boxes as rewards.
But that was to kill, perch.
Any unwarranted reason
to remove a soul,
they claim it to be swift, easy.
Who cares it's just one
less of them premeditated.
One to see it in full flight.
To know of open hand and small
man will become covalent bonds.
Never seem to think twice.
Just react.
Like atoms.
Like justice system.
Like every black man
slammed into the court bench.
Like every family with lost father,
like Tom Robinson, like Atticus.
They are not the body
at the gun range.
Just a noise cancellations.
Our lives just be open statement
using casual conversation.
Something to sign about,
then back to lecture.
They will never know how it feels to
be a mocking bird, or a butterfly.
Or every Tom convicted of a crime
they never even thought to commit,
pushed in to the rifles, then
they play Russian roulette
with intent to kill.
Murder. Displace this life
whatever, whether it be by bullet,
or jail cell, 1933 or 2016
we are always remembered
by how easily black
can turn to crimson.
It was on a Wednesday during
my 11 a.m. chemistry class,
when a butterfly placed itself upon
a student's desk and for a moment,
I knew that it came as a warning.
Thank you.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Audience,
you're doing a good job.
Judges, you're doing
a great job; 3, 2, 1.
Scores up from low to high I
have, a 9.3, a 9.5, and a 9.8.
That's for the poet [cheers].
Keep that energy going for your
next poet in the first round, Julio.
[ Cheers ]
>> JULIO: In 2016, 12 teachers
were murdered for fighting
for educational reform
in Wahaka, Mexico.
I've never been to Wahaka.
But I'll hold the soil with
two palms like a newborn child.
My mother was born there.
Heard the sun was as warm to
melt your heart into a ribcage.
Heard the soil carries the sound
of three million souls
walking to school.
Education isn't close to home here.
The difference between
a book and a child is
that sometimes they're seven
miles apart from each other
and most commonly, the teachers
know the students better
than the parents do.
And maybe sometimes the teachers
will substitute for the students
when the parents are sick, when
the parents are on opposite sides
of the wall, when their
parents are breathing less.
Or when they're breathless.
Wahaka teachers crease
open the floors with seeds,
sprout every child
they can from seeking.
So why do they only get
acknowledgement when 12 of them wind
up dead on the news still arrested
with the their eyes still open.
They never get a chance to blink,
or saw the world spin off its axes.
This is what happens when you
speak on a countries problems,
how crazy it can be for
the Mexican government
to bite off their own fruit.
Why doesn't anybody ever talk
about how good the students are.
What are the students doing?
What's proficient nowadays?
Ask how many miles they
walk to school and calculate
that with the amount of
times they came hungry.
Ask how things are going at home.
But don't be surprised when they ask
you what that last word means, ask,
ask them who their favorite hero is.
And they're reply dead.
Twelve of them to be exact.
Twelve teachers that advocated.
All 12 made national TV.
You can still read the names on
the screen when the TV turned off.
Still hear the screams of
12 generations fighting,
but you probably couldn't.
Sound is always hard
to hear behind a wall.
Always misinterpreted,
always looked over.
How do you kill 12 teachers
and not learn from it?
This will be the first time a
teacher's absent in a classroom.
The first time the students
are actually listening.
The first time 12 teachers raised
their hand at the exact same time
and all got the same answer.
Aren't you tired of watching, or
did you even bother to watch at all?
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up from low to
high I have a 9.5, a 9.8,
and the first 10 of the evening.
[ Cheers ]
We've got 1, 2, 3 poets
left in the first round.
Please keep that energy up.
Start clapping right now
for your next poet, Henry.
All the way to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> HENRY: My parents don't
know about storytelling.
Another word for it is
gossip in their minds.
To spill the secrets out of our
household for everyone to know.
They forget about the tales
they've been told about witches,
and the thieves in the city.
Their tongues are now stale.
They do not speak a native language.
It's never been this cordial.
It is all something
they've memorized.
A knowledge, a script.
My parents know argument.
They know bland dialect
that will split them a half
that won't be quiet.
A half that won't forgive.
Then their conversations
become worrisome.
Their eerie.
Sometimes my father
talks about his dad.
How he saw his own friend drown,
how he then walked home to get sleep
for work the next morning.
My parents had to cross rivers
in order to get to school.
They take their clothes off.
They hold them up high.
There's nothing celestial
about that.
At school, they are only
given disciplinary bruises.
You can't blame the teachers.
Beatings are all my parents afford.
Nearest library is two hours away.
They're not great at reading.
They know numbers, they
know how to part their lips.
My parents don't know many
ways to say, thank you.
They'll nod their head, yes.
They'll send money
back to El Salvador.
Sometimes they'll just look
at you and stay silent.
I told my parents I
wanted to be a writer.
My parents do not know
that they are stubborn.
My parents do not know that
they do not like what has risk.
What isn't stable.
What is out of the norm.
they remind me that
we were never people
who did things out of willingness.
That we only know demand
and conformity.
They remind me that we
have only opened newspapers
to look for coupons.
That no one reads anymore.
And no one cares anymore.
My parents do not know rebirth
through writing [cheer].
Death is given logic
when it is written.
My parents came to this
country rather young.
They do not know travelling.
They know migration,
they know starving.
They have suffered because they
have come to meet them in the face.
But they have never spoken about it.
They live hurt.
Yet, they have never read
something of healing.
And this is the way
I carry when I write.
And this is what I will continue
to carry until everything is said.
Until my parents understand.
Fortunately, my parents know
something about listening.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high I have
a 9.4, a 9.5, and a 9.8.
Let's hear it for the
poet [applause].
Keep that applause going
for you second to last poet,
in the first round, Kalyn Basquez.
[ Applause ]
>> KALYN BASQUEZ: After "Fortress
of Solitude" by Jonathan Lethem.
Dear Gentrifier, when you and
the rest of the hipsters want
to crowd the M train and act like
you all know Williamsburg Brooklyn.
The older Latino people in the
subway car look at me like I'm one
of you, because tattoos
and piercings are white.
Been appropriated so long ago,
we almost forgot it was never
your culture to begin with.
I get off the train
with a bunch of you too
who check the newly placed public
maps to find a restaurant, a bar,
whatever else you colonized here.
Galivant through like you all even
know how to get to the street,
this place was named
after, you can't can you?
Can't tell me which small
business shut down to make room
for the Duane Reed the Whole Foods.
Tell me you love Spanish
food, bodega coffee.
He lump the [inaudible] truck every
night to educate your taste buds.
Forget your presence, price is
out the ones cooking for you.
Tell me you respect culture
and that's why you go
to Afro Punk every year.
Tell me you're for equality and pay
$4 for a cup of yogurt willingly
like my sister's food
stamps ain't got limits.
Like it care about
my nephew stomach.
Tell me when you make a
new geo photo on Snapchat.
Just like you out there
for Washington Heights.
Oops, Wa He.
Because you're all
for renaming New York.
Been a while since the Dutch did it.
So I guess it's time
for something new.
Tell me you're against a new
neighborhood and pay $2 million
for an apartment on the water.
Name the landmarks you
were too drunk to notice.
Tell me about the Domino Sugar
factory, before it was condos.
Like black history wasn't always
just a speed bump for developers.
Like it ain't American history,
unless it's yours tell me
you can build an entire home
out of suffering and broken spines
like slavery was never
abolished after all.
Tell me about Puerto Rico,
that island you noticed
when you were sailing over here.
Tell me how easy it is to find
a cheap plot of land there.
How the sun on your skin makes
you feel like you belong,
because my home ain't safe.
Ain't sacred no matter when it is
and tell me you know all of this
and if you can I still
know it is only
because you are used
to taking things.
[ Cheering ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Poems.
So many poems.
And so many scores.
Judges 3, 2, 1.
Get em up.
From low to high I have
a 9.0, a 9.3, and a 9.4.
Let's hear it for the
poet [applause].
And coming up last in our first
round please put your hands
together, start clapping right
now, for Elondra Brassil.
All the way top the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> ELONDRA BRASSIL: One, two, three.
No, no, no, no.
Two, four, six.
One, two, three, four.
You want me to read it?
the second paragraph?
All of it?
No, no, no, no.
It's fine.
I have a pretty.
I mean, I mean problem with reading.
Growing up with dyslexia,
you spend more time trying
to read your name than write it.
Trying to find the rhythm in words
over alphabets how he's turned
into hes, or just not
understanding the difference.
I love going to birthday parties.
You find out quickly how
your misunderstanding
of words can turn a room silent.
Can turn a reading class,
instructions into the teaching
lesson over the difference
between a's and i's, one sentence
was like a death sentence.
Reading out loud is
like a death sentence.
I can feel my cheeks turn red.
Arms go cold.
Hands tremble.
I've spent 30 seconds telling
you how I feel, but if I wrote it
down I would stumble first grade.
I can read.
I mean I can read.
I swear I can.
Words just run from me.
Second, third.
Third is when I became a
mathematician, counting the number
of people that read before me
did it for like a math problem,
but more like a destination,
fourth, fifth.
Mr. and Mrs. Brassil Elondra
struggles more than most kids.
Sixth, we can help by
putting her into some classes.
Seventh, eighth.
Hi. I'll be your literacy
teacher today.
Does she know that
words run from me?
Does she know that I run from words?
In ninth I learned that boys don't
leave me tongue tied, words do.
I do, I do.
I know the word.
It's on the tip of my tongue.
You notice you can
only use this phrase
so many times before
they stop believing you.
Do you even believe in me anymore?
I mean me.
I mean you.
I mean you know what I mean.
I mean you know what I meant.
Forgetting placements in
books, run-on sentences.
A's turning to i's it's
not normal behavior.
It's a silent hand raised.
It's a kid choosing to act out
because you refuse to read to them.
How do you help someone
with dyslexia?
You let them tell you their story
instead of you forcing them to;
one, two, three [cheers].
Read one.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
what do you think?
3, 2, 1. Scores up.
From low to high I have
a 9.7, a 9.8, and a 9.8.
Clap up for the poet.
[ Applause ]
So, that's the end
of the first round.
You all did it real good.
I'm very proud of you.
Only heard like one random
cellphone tone go off.
Don't do that again.
But real quick before we
jump into this last round.
We're going to take all the poets,
we're going to turn
it back around again.
We're going to go right
back down the list.
We're going to take the two scores,
we're going to add them together
and that's how we're going find out
who's going to win our poetry slam.
But real quick everyone
just look around the room.
Just take a look around the room.
I said this earlier.
But it's practically
standing room only
on a Saturday night
for a poetry slam.
That's a beautiful thing.
Now keep clapping while
we take a picture of this.
[ Applause ]
I can do this.
Everybody, say National
Book Festival.
[ Cheers ]
Oh do it for the gram.
Hi y'all. All right here
we go in this order.
Elondra, Kalyn, Henry, Julio,
Kenya, Kaysa, Shintelli, and Alyssa.
Those are your poets
in the second round.
Make some noise for
them all right now.
Coming right back to the stage,
please put your hands
together for Elondra Brassil.
[ Cheering ]
[ Applause ]
>> ELONDRA BRASSIL: I
just want to be pretty.
Not mama secondhand
compliments type pretty.
But drop dead gorgeous.
Not have to look at my
reflection and regret it.
Have a list of ten things in my
head that I should have fixed,
but ignored them because only
pretty people stare in the mirror
for longer than 10 seconds.
My breasts are getting heavier.
I tried to experiment with different
bras, but they always seem to want
to be the center of attention.
My stomach hangs as low as my faith.
My weight is why my faith
in God is questionable.
I wonder why they call them love
handles if they're unlovable.
It seems like my hips
aren't getting the hints
that my stretchmarks
are trying to give them.
They just keep on expanding.
I eat like I'm going to find
my [inaudible] apology letter
at the bottom of the bag, just to
find my guilt staring back at me.
I can't stare in the
mirror for too long,
I begin to remember why I never do.
That's why I get dressed
with the lights off.
My stretch marks remind me of why I
started cutting in the first place.
I mean, I mean why I wanted
to die in the first place.
Maybe that's why they
call them marks.
Because being overweight
always leaves a scar.
I wonder when my sister told
me I was gaining a few pounds,
did she know I was
gaining insecurities too?
I've been tucking in my
insecurities since I was 12.
Just to picture me in a
crop top makes me all want
to crop myself out.
I avoid doctor appointments
because I know they'll weigh me.
My gym teachers don't know that I'm
dishonest about my weight on tests.
That the only time I
run is past scales.
I wonder when God sees me
does he throw up in his mouth?
Or do I make him regret creating
mirrors in the first place.
I've never felt so
exposed in my life.
I'm standing in front of glass
and I'm the one about to break.
With a bare body and raw emotions.
I let you validate me.
You keep my secrets
hidden in your cracks.
Have no shame and putting
gaps in my confidence.
You and I can't agree on
what I should look like.
You let me pour out my
flaws, just to show them off.
Make my own reflection turn on me.
Turn my body into a homicide.
Make me lose my mind
first instead of pounds.
You make my neck, back, breast,
chin, ass, arms, hands, legs,
stomach into a suicide letter.
And 5 a.m. cries for help.
I can't hide anymore.
I can't hide my weight number
long sleeves and cardigans,
let God shine on all of my flaws
[cheering] expose my wounds
and worship in them.
Would it be cliché if I told
you I'm taking all of me back.
Maybe you'll never see beauty in me.
That my body is what you're framing,
but I don't need you anymore,
because I'm drop dead beautiful.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high I have
a 9.8, a 9.9, and a 10.
[ Cheers ]
Keep that same energy
going for the next poet.
Please put your hands
together for Kalyn Basquez.
[ Applause ]
>> KALYN BASQUEZ: Mama
taught me three things.
It is the man's job to build a
woman into the spine of a bridge.
It is the woman's job not to bleed
through the cement in the process.
God, is always watching
as this unfolds.
When my boyfriend says I'm
stupid, grows furious with me
because I do not want
to have sex with him.
Makes me feel insignificant
and shames me for it.
I feel him melt me down and
spread me over the steel overlays.
Smooth me into a roadway, accordion,
how sweet the sobbing sounds,
when harmonizing of
his blaring engine.
I rate in hot like the sting
of the first time he
snapped at me, God enters.
As how I just stand there
and let him drive me
down to a skid mark, stops.
Says I must get it from my mother.
The way we turn fists into
palms full of love notes.
How we be the food he
devours on the table.
And the table he screws
on afterwards.
Absorb a man's darkness
and still lead him
to a flame he can choose
to blow out at whim.
He kisses my back with his feet.
Stomps across each vertebra as if
I could connect all his broken.
And I saw it coming.
And the way he's scoff at my
magic as if he were Houdini
and I were a backyard act.
The way he'd make requests into law.
Decree. A rewriting of the Bible
that I knew would only
end in apocalypse.
Fooled myself into a fairytale
that played out in the wrong order.
And now here I am.
A nymph for a storyteller that won't
remember by name by the end of it,
but will remember my breasts.
The fertile mound of my stomach,
how women bleed sustenance.
Don't you know our blood is the
binding agent in cement mix?
God clears her throat.
As how I plan to save myself
now that my limbs are encased
in rocks says do you
remember when you were wild?
And I don't.
This hug of concrete
done declawed me.
Done polish me down to token
I stand the worst fashion.
Unmoving. Bones degrading
like my name and his mouth.
God asks remember that
time you loved yourself?
And I claw a crack through the
asphalt hoping my voice can escape.
But by the time the words interrupt
the metal beams there's no one there
to receive them.
God is gone now.
And I do not know if he was there
the whole time to begin with,
or if it was only yearning
to see myself near divinity.
But I know she's always watching.
For the day I snap
the suspender cables.
Split my deck and let
the steel concave itself
into a skull fracturing casket.
Let him cascade down.
Still screaming for
the womb of my love.
God and I will laugh.
It will be the last time I let
a man make a highway of me.
And that part.
I taught my own damn self.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to, why you?
From low to high I have a 9.5.
a 9.6 and a 9.7.
Let's hear it for the poet [cheers].
Keep that same energy going.
Coming back to the stage, Henry.
[ Applause ]
>> HENRY: I come from
a family of repent.
My mother fell in love.
My father was a cigarette
addict I was wrapped
in that same evangelical blanket.
I grew up learning how to get
comfortable to sleep on pews.
I grew up learning how to close
my eyes and have conversation.
I grew up learning how to
not get stomped on by those
who danced in time of praise.
No church boy, they're asked
to think of God unworthy.
I was probably one of the only
little boys that paid attention.
I had this trust and fear
in God it was this being
that could turn our church, a
school cafeteria into a sanctuary.
We borrowed music stands from
classrooms, used them as pulpits.
When I was eight, I
finally stood behind one.
I preached in front
of other 8-year-olds
and the pastor's youngest son.
I delve into the stout
book of "Revelation."
I spoke about the rapture,
horns blowing, a blood moon.
I became a holy infant at church.
I learned to walk,
I became a priest.
My father had me memorize
this verse.
I don't remember it completely now.
It was about a believer
who rebelled.
About a dog that returns
to its own vomit.
Shortly after the understanding
of God comes the absorption
of what baptism is.
I began to take baptism classes.
Most of the people there
are in their forties.
We had read the same book.
We know that baptism is not a toy.
It is a seal embossed onto your
spiritual and physical being.
And it is not a toy.
It is not guaranteed for
it to be a good thing
to be baptized at an early age.
Jesus was baptized when he was 30.
I was baptized a couple
weeks before I turned 12.
Our congregation was going to
be uniting at another church.
We did not own our
own baptismal pools.
I remember getting my white robe.
The man who tied it had
very unstable hands,
they tremble mirrored the great
crumble of Sodom and Gomorrah.
That evening I bathed
in God's waters.
They were welcoming, but lukewarm.
I had this conversation the
day before with my mother.
It still lingers with me.
She mentioned how young I was
and the greater repercussions
of sin that came with it.
I was just an eager boy.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges let me
see those scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high I have a.
We have a 9.1, a 9.2 and a 9.3.
Let's hear it for the
poet [applause].
If you're having a
good time say yeah.
If you're having a real
good time say oh yeah.
Coming up next to the stage, please
keep that energy going for Julio.
[ Cheers ]
[ Applause ]
>> JULIO: A letter to Mi abuela.
I love you.
Even if you hate that I say it
in English sometimes it
still carries the rich rivers
of [foreign word] mango juice.
Your favorite.
I know you grandma.
I know English is foreign
on your tongue the same
way it is to your ears.
But I promise it will
find its way to your heart
through the creases of your smile.
Let it soak in.
Your teeth shine like you
ate diamonds breakfast.
Your cheeks are the color of
caramel syrup on pancakes.
Carousels cover the color of
your eyes and I could surf
on the cursive of your hair.
You are the surface of the sun.
So, beautiful and so bright.
The world needs to notice you more.
Nobody every appreciates how
gorgeous the sun is until it's gone.
I acknowledge your struggle grandma.
I know raising six kids in
a room wasn't your fault.
Single mothers go through
thorns and flames.
But you made it out just fine.
I know your palms still ache
from holding the ceiling in place
for my mother, my aunts, my uncles.
You are the strongest woman I know.
You cradled all six of your
children on your smile.
Even if you knew there'd
be no food that night.
Love becomes a five-course
meal, you need to stay alive.
And I feel your pain, grandma.
I know having people
taking advantage of you
because of what you can't
comprehend is cruel.
It's ignorance.
They only love Spanish culture
when it's not affecting them.
This is not a poem about me though,
but when my grandma tells me what
is the point of learning English
if I'll be gone before I
can say I love you back.
It feels like I failed her.
Like I disappoint her.
It hurts to see my
grandma struggle with words
like language is another
barrier she has to sneak past.
Her mouth has been boarded
up like empty homes.
My grandma is an empty home, lonely.
But she stands bold with no support.
I feel your hardships, grandma.
The ocean tried to swallow you.
You had some hardships grandma.
Your name will never
sink in these waters.
I tied a rope to every
syllable of your name just
in case it falls under pressure.
And I am still above water.
Every vein in your body
connects to your heart,
like all bridges lead to kingdoms.
I love seeing my mother happy
because I can see my
grandmother smile
as well, like a two for one deal.
I'm all about finding
the value in love
because my grandmother knew
struggle, way before she knew joy.
She knew rape before sex.
Almost like she knew
scars before scabs.
She broke the ocean
in half to get here.
She is the strongest woman I know.
Dear grandma, truth is I wrote
this poem for you years ago,
and every family dinners, every
barbecues, every Sunday mornings,
I'm learning to appreciate
doing all those things with you.
Because you help be grow.
Once more, gracias abuela.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high I have a 9.8,
a 9.8, and a 10 [applause].
Keep that energy going.
Coming up next, put your hands, or
keep your hands going for Kenya.
All the way to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> KENYA: I binge watch
Netflix like a child looking
for candy in church, religiously.
And my favorite show has always
been "Orange is the New Black."
Tells jail from the feminine side.
So, it's all for the little woman
who doesn't think she
deserves to be incarcerated.
Has a life too good for the system.
I think I fell in love
with the fairytale aspect,
like all jail were formatories.
Where lifelong friends are made
and the food isn't the best.
Call it summer camp for criminals.
But, the sun always sets
on someone else's horizon.
Serving some crime
fiction, to reality.
More like a spec of our reality.
Shows police brutality
as a papercut.
Just another one of our issues,
to profit off, this is the trend.
Suddenly for the audience until
their ready to vow another meal
to our stories to write before their
tongue spit us out and it burns.
Let's see your own crucified,
pinned down, left breathless,
then have the nerve to say
that you can't breathe.
Even weakened black skin has
turned into bragging rights.
You need to think of a new plot
for your next season of the way,
to increase your fan base of the
black body swiped under the flag.
Be careful, you might
reveal the millions
of message your people
have made, why?
Does no one want to own up to,
I mean clean up the
messes they've made.
I know I've heard the story before.
Too many times I've been [inaudible]
reliving these moments but we always
for get to read the
preface of the novel.
No one wants to know the
beginning of the horror film,
this storyline has become too
relatable, just ask the victims
of any city education, or
down south voter booths.
This country has classified
too many of us as villains,
writing [inaudible]
"Suicide Squad" proclaim
to protect these streets here.
They delete the forward.
Just skip to the appendix.
You become as transparent at the
Constitution's copyright whether
in Ferguson or Lynch Field.
We are always the cliff hanger.
We are never the last one standing,
but the first ones on our feet.
Too many of our spines
have sacrificed just
to keep this story together, just to
bind severed mouths to our wrists.
We always end up cleaning
the blood stains anyway.
Never knew this is white carpet.
Seems to make sense now.
How we always knew what occurred
and wearing at the generation
of scrubbing motives, the only
things that never come out.
But you call us the animal.
Place us in cages and tell us
to be civilized, forces to choke
on your keys, while you
proceed to close the gates.
Release the menace and
smile into the camera.
Life, at our gasp for
life or freedom.
As the scene fads into your bodies
with fear set upon our
face, spoiler alert.
We're prosecuted for claiming
this last breath to ever be ours.
Why is it that we're never able
to attend our own curtain calls?
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges
scores in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to high.
You all are making such a mess.
We have a 9.5, a 9.5, and a 9.6.
Let's hear it for the poet.
[ Cheers ]
As you may imagine.
It is not an easy thing putting
on an event of this size.
And I don't mean just this slam.
I mean like this entire book fair.
And it could not have
been done without the help
of a bunch of volunteers.
So, I want you all to look around
the room and you see the people
in these blue shirts back there?
I want you all to give them a
really loud round of applause.
[ Applause ]
And then, for making
this place as accessible
as possible our interpreters here,
I would like to give them
a round of applause also.
[ Applause ]
Coming up next to the stage,
please put your hands
together for Kaysa [applause].
I'm right am I accurate,
is it happening?
Oh, there she is.
[ Applause ]
>> KAYSA: I was born
in Anderson, Indiana.
My mother a native to the town.
Engine failed to ignite.
My galaxy was closing in on me.
A town where there's
either a church, cornfield
or liquor store on every corner.
Houston, we have a problem.
My future seems distance,
I'm tailored to my ship
but everything seems
so far out of reach.
My mother knows everybody
who's anybody,
because of her body
she's hard to miss.
Loud mouth caramel skin and
thick flesh adorn her bones.
Access denied.
Something's missing.
Where's my copilot, who should have
been my father was merely a faded
shadow in my faded memory.
A far-out satellite
circling my world.
Abort mission.
My memory can't retain.
ADHD gets in my way an asteroid in
close range, which switch do I use.
The first time I heard the
words behavioral disorder,
I was in the second grade.
And I wish it would only be the
second time I felt like an outsider.
Outside of this orbit.
Outside of the classroom I sat into.
I couldn't find my act.
I stayed hidden, out
of sight, out of mind.
I stayed hidden away from the
gleam they call the bright future.
My family always taught
me education was key.
Go to school.
Get your degree.
My grandfather would
say to me, my poppy.
Average build, mentally sound,
grey hair lining his mahogany skin.
He's the strongest man I
know and black don't crack,
but I've seen his brain matter
explode like black matter
by the fact that he lacks an
education prior to the 21st century.
By the sixth grade I was
a 21st century scholar,
which meant I could attend any
college in the State of Indiana
and it would be paid for.
This was the first time my
mother found faith in the system.
Her heart thundered
and her eyes pixeled
when she realized I
could wear a white collar
as a black woman in
corporate America.
System override.
This isn't supposed to happen.
They're paying my dues because
my mother has everything to lose.
She falls below the poverty line.
So, she sends me on
this mission on alone.
So, I tried to defy gravity,
as often did my teachers.
It lost star out of its
orbit like a rocket repelling
into the earth's atmosphere
of education.
I need to know how far I've come.
Show me a demonstration of
the progress I'm making.
I was always told to
reach for the stars.
And I never gave up, yet
I was always let down.
Check levels.
My capsule's going off course.
I've been directed to a new galaxy.
The galaxy of Rhonda.
My aunt's big-busted
personality as wide
as the giant system of the earth.
A laugh that rings through
outer space, bringing people in.
She is my new galaxy.
I can stop reaching for the stars,
because she has put them among me.
Her only request is that I choose
one that shines as bright as I do,
so I don't become a falling ball of
dust that once embellished the sky.
I've chosen the sun.
The creations of this world.
The particle of our galaxy.
All made up as we know it but
this isn't the big bang theory.
This the phenomena of my life.
Engine rebooted.
I am burning through the
solar system of education.
My brain like jet fuel,
my thoughts the presence
of planets, rare and majestic.
Everything I am is made
up of tiny stars and ideas
as grand as this universe.
I, me and my star have become one.
My bones and flesh are wrapped in
string that tie me to the planet
to let me gaze among the stars.
This theory has been proven.
Mission complete.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Strong
young people.
Judges scores please in 3, 2, 1.
Scores up.
From low to, I have a 9.5.
a 9.7 and a 9.7.
Let's hear it for the
poet please [cheers].
Two more competitors left
in this amazing slam,
if you're having a good time
make some noise [cheers].
Oh, it feels good.
Coming up next please
put your hands together
for Shintelli Medina [applause].
All the way to the stage, folks.
All the way to the stage.
[ Applause ]
>> SHINTELLI MEDINA: Today I wear
a blue dress two sizes too large.
I don't want to force
anyone to froth at the mouth
of rampage uncontrollably.
My blue dress tames my
curves, so I walk unabashed.
Yet, man is taught it speak
things into existence.
You're sexy.
My tempo is brought forth,
readies itself for demolition.
Man gawks at me, uses his eyes
to enter the body I've
tried my best to hide.
Man calls me ma.
And now I am his mother.
Forced to feel like I should
discipline him, demand some respect.
Man yells, baby.
And now I'm an infant.
Gut tells me I should yell,
scream, cry make it clear
that what he's calling
me isn't my name.
Apparently I don't live here.
This ain't my private property.
I'm free to the public for viewing.
Man says sheesh, girl, smile.
He wants me to take his
oppression for appreciation.
Man has the nerve to stare at me.
Up and down.
Hard and steadfast waiting
for some kind of gratitude.
To be thanked for trespassing,
waits for a smile.
Some indication that this
is what we both want.
I am barely restraining the bullet
burning to be roared out of me.
My eyes are unrelenting
black pebbles.
I can't swallow this man's audacity.
His patience silences questions
if it's really rejection,
or just the front before the yes.
Pauses to see if I really don't
want to share myself with him.
Man smooches as if
to call a lost pet.
But I will no longer allow
his words to domesticate me.
The morphing stops now.
I speak myself into existence.
I am only what I say I am
when I walk down the street.
I am not your mother,
your baby, your girl.
My ultimate form is dragon.
Every time you belittle me
with your words, your eyes,
my jaw widens, teeth sharpen.
I thirst for blood.
This is a warning to all the
men who take my blue dress
as an invitation to my body.
Who don't let me pass them without
yelling sexy, Ms. Beautiful,
Ms. Guts with a fat ass,
ma, baby girl, I am a woman.
And the beast.
Still want to see me smile?
Still want what's under my dress?
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges may I
please hear your scores in 3, 2, 1.
low to high I have
a 9.9, and two 10s.
[ Cheers ]
All right.
Calm down.
But not really because we
have one more poet left.
All right.
Keep that energy going,
start clapping right now
for your last poet, Alyssa Gaines.
[ Applause ]
>> ALYSSA GAINES: I went
to my friend named September's 13th
birthday party, in rural Indiana,
where I had to convince her
to take the Confederate flag
down so that I could come.
I still went to the party
but the damage was done.
The reason I was so hurt was
because still in our county,
innocent blacks are
being slain by police.
And people have the nerve to display
a flag of prejudice racial history.
She wondered why I was so upset.
July 13, 2013 George
Zimmerman found not guilty.
Where was she when the verdict was
in when six non-black women
said, Zimmerman was innocent.
I was in Florida when
they picked the jurors.
My Mam ma's house when
they gave the verdict.
I remember in my journal I wrote
how they just gave him his gun
like we're sorry, sir,
you're free to go.
And it hurts that my mother must
tell my 8-year-old brother the way
to behave if he ever
gets pulled over.
It's like what you don't hear in
the police shooting recordings.
The one thing they're
missing, the warning.
Be compliant.
Keep your hands in the sky
and explain the situation.
Drop your weapon.
But the weapon I can't drop
is the reason I'm a target.
It's because I'm black, woke and
politically conscious [cheering].
No justice, no peace.
No racist police.
No killing innocent blacks and
leaving their bodies in the streets.
Hashtag black lives matter
because police are not
treating us like all lives do.
When I say black lives matter,
how could that offend blue.
How, after everything we've
been through it's rude.
How is it socially unacceptable to
fear for my little brother's life.
How if I dread the day he
learns how to drive and voice
that it's impolite, because
black people are being persecuted
by police who receive paid leave.
And if you really believe that all
lives mattered why don't you stand
with black ones in our
time of need [cheers].
When people talk about
breast cancer,
would you say all cancers
matter, so why are people mad,
is the operative word black?
And oh, the irony.
It's funny almost people say blue
lives matter, when all jobs do
and their defense is they
never said that all jobs don't.
See we say things like
black lives matter every day
and nobody combats it because
black isn't what we say.
And legality is only a technicality
when it comes to police brutality.
What if, September, your
dad, or your little brother
or your uncle was at risk.
Would you stay peaceful?
Would you stay quiet?
Would you enjoy being
told how to handle it?
No, I'm upset because I'm tired
of hearing the officers
have not been charged.
Or they were acquitted and there was
so much evidence they
could have admitted.
And the one shooting that made me
particularly mad was Charles Kinsey
he was laying hands up on his back.
It showed no matter how much my
mother teaches my brother, MJ,
even if he does what
the officers say.
Even if all the talking
he does is to explain.
Even if he's protecting
a man with autism.
All lives can't matter until
black lives do and I won't quit
until every September
realizes that it's
for these innocent people
whose killer's not punished.
Whose body's scattered,
that I'm here
with my fists high
proclaiming black lives matter.
[ Cheers ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Judges let me
hear those scores in 3, 2, 1.
From low to, I have three 10s.
[ Cheering ]
So, I've done my part.
I've kept my mouth shut.
I've said nothing in
between these poems.
The entire night.
The hardest job in the room
is to keep silent when all
of this truth is being
spilled out into this space.
If you were moved tonight.
If you heard something that inspired
you tonight, please make some noise
for these eight poets
that came on this stage.
[ Cheers ]
You shouldn't be sitting.
That's for y'all good job.
Doesn't seem to be enough.
All right.
We still have to do some math.
We want to award.
We have some books and
some gift certificates
and things we want to
give to the people.
So, we're doing some
math real quick.
While that math is happening,
this event was brought to you
by The Library of Congress, the
National Endowment of the Arts,
and by Split This Rock and
right now, I would like to bring
to the stage the executive director
of Split This Rock to tell you
about all the amazing work we
have going on there right now.
Please put your hands together
for Sarah Browning [applause].
I'll take a hug.
>> SARAH BROWNING: Joseph
Green everyone [applause].
My incredible colleague.
Split This Rock is a national
organization based here in DC.
We cultivate, teach and celebrate
poetry that bears witness
to injustice and provokes change.
I think you've heard
some of that tonight.
[ Applause ]
Our youth programs are
throughout the Washington DC area.
The young people you've heard
from DC, from Indianapolis,
from Des Moines, from New York City.
They are the future of poetry.
They are the future of literature.
They are the future of our country.
Is your hope restored?
Is your hope restored in
the future of our country?
These are our leaders.
These are our leaders to come.
Who all is here from
the DC area [cheers].
All right we got DC in the house.
We got Virginia in the house
we got Maryland in the house,
make some noise [applause].
And Joseph is ready.
Dun, da Dun.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: May I have
all the poets access the stage.
>> SARAH BROWNING: All the poets.
All these brilliant young people.
[ Applause ]
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Come join me.
Come join me.
So, Sarah will you let them know
what the prizes are real quick?
All right.
>> SARAH BROWNING: I sure will.
So, we have the most beautiful,
most recent book by one
of our finest poets, and
the judge tonight Joy Harjo,
"Conflict Resolution for Holy
Beings" for the top three winners.
Yes, and Joy will sign
them to you personally.
And then the number one poet,
the one who got those numbers,
yeah the highest scores will
also get a $50 gift certificate
to Politics and Pros Independent
Bookstore here in Washington, DC,
but you can order online
from the bookstore.
You can order online.
All right.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: All right.
In third place with a 58.2
please put your hands together
for Alyssa Gaines.
[ Applause ]
From Indianapolis, Indy Pulse.
In second place, Julio
from RunDSM, Des Moines.
[ Applause ]
How you doing?
You feeling good?
I got some good news for you.
I really like your poems.
And you did a really
good job tonight.
I liked everybody's poems you all
did like a really good job tonight.
I was super impressed.
Super impressed.
However, because we have to
add together the numbers,
in first place, from Des Moines,
please put your hands
together for Elondra Brassil.
[ Applause ]
I'm going to get that right.
Can everyone be quiet real quick.
Everyone calm down.
I did so good all night.
I did so good all night
I had the names spelled
out phonetically on my paper.
I was feeling so good.
I want the winner to have
their name said correctly.
Can you please tell the
people how to say your name?
ELONDRA BRASSIL: Elondra Brassil.
>> JOSEPH GREEN: Please
clap for her.
[ Applause ]
On behalf of the Library
of Congress,
on Behalf of the National
Endowment of the Arts,
on behalf of Split This Rock,
my name is Joseph Green.
It's been my pleasure.
Thank you so very much for coming.
Please support the arts.
Have a wonderful night.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.